-Welcome back. Did you --
That was stressful.
-Yeah.
I have, like, quite
an adrenaline rush right now.
-You do?
-Yes, I do.
-But do you like this?
Is this the way
we should always do it?
A game with you before we talk?
-Yeah, it kind of breaks the ice
in a nice way.
My heart rate is
still really high.
-I'm very competitive.
I'm sorry about that, yeah.
-I didn't know that I would be
decent, actually.
And I -- So that was --
that's good.
-You were phenomenal,
by the way.
-I felt like I was okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were more than decent.
You were more than decent.
-I just thought it was going to
be real bad,
and I wasn't as bad as, well.
-This interesting though to me
because last time you were
on the show,
we were talking about
"Doctor Strange."
-Yes, we were.
-And you were like, "I don't --
I don't -- Jimmy, I don't know.
I never know if the movie is
going to be big or not big.
I just don't know. I do my best
and blah, blah, blah."
And I go,
"It's going to be giant."
You were like, "I just don't --
I don't know."
And it went on to make
over $950 million.
-I don't know.
-Almost a billion dollars.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know.
-What do you mean
you don't know?
-No, but I guess it did. It did.
-It definitely did it.
Yes, it did.
It's a giant, massive hit.
-That's a wild number.
-It's an insane number.
-It's a weird number that I
can't really --
I don't know what
to equate it to, those numbers.
-But you haven't seen it still?
-No, I haven't seen it still.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Is it because, just,
you don't see your own movies?
Are you one of those?
-I wish.
No, I'm not one of those.
I'm like one of those people
who, like, wants to study
something so I can figure out
how to make it better.
-Yeah.
So you just haven't gotten
around to it.
-No. I had a cold when we had
the premiere,
and I didn't want to
sit through it.
-You did have a cold?
-I did have a cold.
-I remember that.
-And then I -- Yes,
because I was here,
and you gave me that spray.
-Yeah. Did it work?
-It was fabulous.
-Alright, good.
-Yeah.
And so I asked them to send me
a copy so I could watch it.
And it was -- like, it had
my name on it,
and then it had
the time I was watching it
And I didn't want to watch it
like that.
-Oh, because it's Marvel,
it's very tricky when you --
-Yes.
-They call them the screeners.
And if they give you a screener
of a movie,
you go, "Oh, my gosh."
But they put a watermark on it
in case you somehow sell it
illegally.
-Yeah, so my name would be on
it, and the exact time and date.
-Imagine if you did that.
-And it was just distracting.
Could you imagine
if I did do that?
-It doesn't seem like you
at all, to me, to do that.
-How do you even do that?
Like, who do you send it to?
Like, how do you even record it
on a computer?
-I tried to do it
when I was a kid
in high school with two VCRs.
[ Laughter ]
-That's how I watched
the Olympics.
I would leave a VHS tape
in the TV
and then I would record it
while I was at school.
-Well, I think you're allowed to
do that.
-Oh, yeah, yeah,
you're allowed to.
You're trying to do something
illegal.
-I was doing something illegal.
Yeah, and I got busted.
They had a thing. It would go
dark and light, dark and light
and it was clearly -- I couldn't
make money that way, yeah.
-Whoa, you were trying to
bootleg stuff
like on the streets
of your school?
-No, no, no, I think just make
a copy for myself.
I didn't have to keep renting
"Pee-Wee's Big Adventure."
[ Laughter ]
-I see. I see.
-"I can't keep doing this."
Are you going to do more Marvel?
-I hope so.
They don't tell me anything
about my fate. So I --
-They don't even let you know
that you're coming back?
-No. I don't know.
-But you're --
I mean, you can --
-I should come back.
-Yeah, of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course you should come back.
-But I really -- I don't know.
I want, like, fans to be,
like, so aggressive, you know,
and, like, terrify them into
doing it or something.
I mean, that's not a good way
to do anything actually.
I really take that back.
-Well, the fans love you.
-Yeah. No one needs to use,
like, force.
-No. We love you.
We just want to see more of you.
-I would love to do more.
-"WandaVision," you just crushed
that as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I would do that --
I would love any -- I would love
any of the -- all of the above.
All of the above.
-Yeah. And I'll watch the movie.
-Yes.
-It's streaming, I heard.
-Yes, it is. There you go.
And your name will be on it just
for a little bit at the top.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then you're in
the whole movie.
Can we talk about this?
-Yes, please.
-Last time you were here,
we unveiled the cover
"Hattie Harmony:
Worry Detective."
And I was very excited
because I love kids books.
-Yes.
You write beautiful kids books.
-No, no, but I just love reading
them too.
Trust me. There couldn't be more
kids books written in the world
'cause I just need -- I'm tired
of the same book.
I've read them. I've tried to
push them to the other side
of the room, they keep ending
back and I'm like,
"Alright, let's read it again.
'Good Night, Moon,' here we go!"
[ Laughter ]
And it's good, but I'm ready for
some new classics.
But this one,
tell me about this.
You wrote this during
the pandemic with your...?
-Yes, I did, with my husband.
And we were already wanting to
write children's books
pre-pandemic.
And it made sense to write one
about children's mental wellness
or really just dealing with
worries and anxieties for kids
and teaching them emotional
language for the first time.
So, it's "Hattie Harmony: Worry
Detective," and she is a cat
who goes to school called
Wildwood Elementary.
And she helps her friends
identify their worries.
And then she gives them tools
on how to deal with it.
-It's so cute. I love it.
[ Applause ]
Marissa Valdez does
the illustrations.
-Yeah, very cute illustrations.
If I do say so myself.
-Yeah, I love the --
This is where someone has
butterflies in their stomach,
and she gets a butterfly net
to get them out.
-Pearl Peppercorn,
the porcupine,
has butterflies in her stomach.
-I saw there's -- there's this
photo that you and your husband
have been doing that's going
around on the Internet.
-Yeah.
-Of I want to say flat Hattie?
-Flat Hatties.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. This is flat Hattie.
Where are you here?
-We're in Italy pre-getting
COVID.
-Yeah. This is before, yeah.
-Yeah, and so, we'd take Hattie
with us wherever we'd go.
And my husband carries her
literally everywhere --
the gym, Dodger games.
-Yeah.
I love that -- here it is --
-We're really big Dodger fans.
-You're giant Dodger fans.
-We're giant Dodger fans.
And so, every single player with
a kid on the team,
they don't know this yet,
but they will be getting
a "Hattie Harmony."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-'Cause you love them that much?
-We love the Dodgers.
-But anyone out there, you can
draw your Hattie Harmonys
and start Flat Hattie'ing
around wherever you are.
Is it true that I heard
Hattie is here tonight?
-It is true.
-Somewhere in the audience.
-She's a really big fan.
-She's a fan?
-She's a big fan of "The Tonight
Show" and the Roots.
-And the Roots, of course.
-And so she wanted to be here.
-Can we see her?
Oh, there she is. Oh, my gosh.
-And that's my beautiful
husband, Robbie Arnett.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, of course, that is
your awesome husband.
Hey, buddy, good to see you,
pal.
Congrats on the book.
Congratulations on the book.
Have a great summer.
Thank you for being here.
Thanks for playing.
Elizabeth Olsen, everybody.
"Hattie Harmony: Worry
Detective" is available now.
Gaten Matarazzo joins us
after the break. Stick around.